- [Alonzo] When I found Back on My Feet,
I was in a dark place.
But I knew that if I can just run,
(train tracks clacking)
things'd get better.
(groovy music)
- [Man] Who are we?
- [Group] Back on My Feet!
- [Man] How long we gonna run?
- [Group] Forever!
- [Alonzo] Back on My Feet was a catalyst
for turning my life around.
- [Woman] Look at that energy.
- You just show up and
just get it out there.
Once you get that pace and your
body gets into another zone,
then you're a distance
runner. (breathes heavily)
When I'm running, I
think about my daughter.
It's a spiritual connection.
When I was a kid, I waited
for my father to pick me up,
and he never showed.
I don't want her to go
through what I went through.
I want her to feel love.
Name is Alonzo Harris.
I'm just a humble man
looking for a better way.
That's 20, keep it moving.
(groovy music)
(electronic chiming)